♪ ♪
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN SET TO MEET
JUNE 16TH IN GENEVA,
SWITZERLAND, WITH NO
PRECONDITIONS RATE IS ISN'T
MEDIA GOING TO ACCUSE BAD ENOUGH
BEING BEING A KGB AGENT?
HERE IS THE WHITE HOUSE
DEFENDING IT.
>> WE DON'T REGARD THE MEETING
FOR THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT, WE
REGARDED AS A VITAL PART OF
DEFENDING AMERICA'S INTEREST AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S MEETING WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN BECAUSE OF
AMERICA'S INTERESTS, NOT IN
SPITE OF THEM.
>> Jesse: REMEMBER HOW
JOE BIDEN APPROVED THAT HUGE
GIVEAWAY TO RUSSIA, NOT A BIG
DEAL.
>> TO GO AHEAD AND POST
SANCTIONS FOR NOW, IN TERMS OF
OUR RELATIONS.
>> Jesse: ALL RIGHT, DANA, YOU
ARE PROBABLY FAMILIAR WITH THE
VIEW OF THESE BIG HIGH-LEVEL
MEETINGS, SHOULD THERE BEEN
PRECONDITIONS?
>> Dana: THERE MIGHT BE SOME
IN PRIVATE, YOU CAN KIND OF HAVE
YOUR OWN, RIGHT, BUT THIS WILL
BE THEIR FIRST CHANCE TO MEET, I
WOULD IMAGINE THAT PUTIN IS LIKE
YEAH, WHAT YOU GOT?
I CAN OUTLAST YOU AND IN HIS
MIND HE'S RUNNING CIRCLES AROUND
AMERICA AND QUICKLY ON THIS, I
GET IT THAT IT'S ALMOST FINISHED
BUT THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE WAS
SOMETHING WHERE YOU DIDN'T WANT
TO UPSET YOU EUROPEAN ALLIES BUT
WHAT ABOUT YOUR NEIGHBORS TO THE
NORTH, WHAT DO CANADIANS DO?
HELLO, WE WERE GOING TO HAVE
THIS, AND IF THE ISSUE IS
CLIMATE CHANGE, THE CLIMATE IS A
GLOBAL ISSUE.
THE PIPELINE IS THERE ANYWAY.
THIS MEETING WILL BE HIGHLY
SCRUTINIZED AND FOR ALL THE
PEOPLE WHO SUGGESTED
PRESIDENT TRUMP WASN'T TOUGH
ENOUGH ON RUSSIA, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE FACTS, COME DOWN TO THE
SUMMIT MEETING I THINK WILL BE A
VERY INTERESTING COMPARISON.
I WOULDN'T HAVE CALLED IT A
SUMMIT.
>> Jesse: Y?
>> Dana: I THINK THAT MAKES IT
TO GRAND.
I WOULD'VE SAID WE ARE GOING TO
GET TOGETHER FOR COFFEE AND
THAT'S IT.
>> Jesse: MAYBE SOME ORANGE
GATORADE, HOW ABOUT A LITTLE
ORANGE GATORADE?
>> Juan: TO ME IT'S NOT LIKE
TRUMP MEETING WITH KIM JONG UN
WAS NO PRECONDITIONS, ALL
KIM JONG UN WANTED WAS THE
MEETING.
THAT PUT THEM ON THE WORLD STAGE
AS A WORLD LEADER AND IN THIS
CASE NOBODY DOUBTS THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS THE LEADER OF
A POWERFUL NATION BUT I THINK
GOING INTO THIS IT IS BIDEN WHO
HAS THE UPPER HAND, CLEARLY WHO
WOULDN'T BET ON TRUMP IN '16, HE
DOUBLED DOWN AN '20 AND HE LOST,
WHAT IS BIDEN GOING TO DO?
WHAT ABOUT THAT COLONIAL
PIPELINE HACK, WHAT ABOUT
ELECTION INTERFERENCE,
VLADIMIR PUTIN?
WHAT ABOUT THE WAY THAT AMASSING
TROOPS ON THE BORDER IN UKRAINE?
ALL OF THAT IS NOT SOMETHING
VLADIMIR PUTIN WANTS TO TALK
ABOUT, HE CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO
WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT WAS
SOMEONE WHO HAS THE POWER OF
JOE BIDEN IN TERMS OF THE
ECONOMIC POWER OVER RUSSIA.
>> Jesse: I AGREE WITH THAT,
WE ALWAYS HAVE THE UPPER HANDS
AS AMERICANS BUT HE ALREADY
CLEARED THEM, HE SAID PUTIN HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE HACK AND
LET OFF THE HOOK.
>> Greg: IT'S INTERESTING WHEN
OUTGOING PRESIDENT OBAMA MET
WITH DONALD TRUMP, HE TOLD HIM
THAT THE MOST VITAL, URGENT
THREAT FACING THE UNITED STATES
WAS NORTH KOREA.
NORTH KOREA WHICH WE DON'T EVEN
TALK ABOUT ANYMORE.
WHY IS THAT?
BECAUSE OF THAT NO PRECONDITION
MEETING THAT TRUMP HAD WITH
KIM JONG UN WHICH REMOVED A
PSYCHOLOGICAL BARRIER AND A
PSYCHOLOGICAL THREAT FROM OUR
COUNTRY.
WE ALL REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED IN
HAWAII, PEOPLE THOUGHT THEY WERE
GOING TO DIE AND WE DON'T EVEN
TALK ABOUT IT ANYMORE.
LITERALLY SCRATCH THAT OFF THE
LIST OF URGENT THREATS.
THAT'S PRETTY AMAZING, THAT
WOULD'VE WON ANY DEMOCRAT A
NOBEL PRIZE BUT OF COURSE WHAT
DOES PUTIN HAVE ON JOE BIDEN?
CONSIDERING THAT HUNTER BIDEN'S
ACTUAL REAL LIFE MAKES THE
STEELE DOSSIER SOUND LIKE
WINNIE THE POOH, I THINK CLEARLY
PUTIN HAS BIDEN IN HIS POCKET,
JOE COULD BE A RUSSIAN ASSET.
PERHAPS THE MANCHURIAN
CANDIDATE, MAYBE EVEN MENTALLY
ILL, WE SHOULD CONSIDER THE 20TH
AMENDMENT.
I LIKE TO QUOTE RACHEL MADDOW,
TICK, TICK, TICK, TICK, BOOM.
>> Jesse: AFTER THAT MEETING
FOR THREE YEARS NORTH KOREA
DIDN'T TEST A LONG-RANGE MISSILE
OR MAJOR BOMB.
BIG EXPECTATIONS FOR THIS
MEETING?
I HAVE A FEELING THE MEETING IS
MEDIA IS GOING TO MAKE JOE LOOK
LIKE G.I. JOE.
>> Dagen: THEY WILL TRY BUT IN
TERMS OF THE TIMING, NOT JUST
THE COLONIAL PIPELINE HACK, IT'S
NOT JUST A GIFT TO RUSSIA, THE
PIPELINE INTO GERMANY, WHAT
ABOUT THE IMMENSE PROXY IN
BELARUS.
THE TIMING DOES LOOK LIKE A
REWARD, A GIANT CAKE WRAPPED IN
A BOX WITH A HUGE BOW ON IT.
WHAT IS BIDEN GOING TO SAY TO
PUTIN?
CUT CUT IT OUT?
AND ONE MORE THING, JOE BIDEN
CALLED PUTIN A KILLER, SO WHY IS
HE SO ANXIOUS TO SIT DOWN NEXT
TO A MURDERER?
>> Jesse: WE WILL FIND OUT